for the most realistic players ever
created in a FIFA title to fully realize
the arenas with living pitches this year
we brought a whole new level of visuals
to the game one of the first things
you'll notice in FIFA 15 is just how
authentic players look to their real
life counterparts our overhauled
lighting system vastly changes how
players appear creating a much more
natural environment and a true-to-life
look a new character models and body
rigging will make players build powerful
and Fletcher you'll also notice
incredible new features like visible
breathing and hair movement you'll see
kits move realistically and visibly get
dirty with both the mud and grass as the
match unfolds on the pitch itself boots
and slide tackles will now leave marks
on the ground as the match goes on the
playing surface becomes increasingly
weathered just as it would in a real
match in wet weather games rain spray
and Avery will kick up off the turf as
players battle for the ball stadiums
will now include animated LED boards
corner flags will now move and gold
frames will rapidly be shot smashes off
the bar or lift off the ground if a
strike will rifle
back of the net incredible visuals is
only one part of the FIFA 15 story
subscribe to our YouTube channel to see
more upcoming innovations including
emotion and intensity and player control